you know everything drives me crazy
about gary i'll be honest he knows that
i've told you that i was in my office
playing tapes of gary's audiobook
and i'm playing it and i'm saying to
myself who who
would buy this book it's it's torture
and no offense gary i mean i know it's a
terrible thing to say
okay thank you i said to the guy send me
a bunch of clips because maybe we could
use them on the show
and gary's turning 60. i thought well
maybe it'll be a good time to celebrate
gary it's funny you say that like i've
really come to like hate my birthdays
now because you guys
always seem to celebrate them for me in
such a way that makes me feel so good
about myself
[Laughter]
gary prides himself on being an expert
on all things music so he first
realized this passion in seventh grade
art class
it was close to the end of the 1974
school year our teacher was a hippie who
had the windows open
and music playing on a radio i looked
totally cool that day in a pair of flame
red bell bottoms
and i was about to prove i was so much
cooler as we were painting and listening
to the music
the song band on the run came on the
cute girl at the easel next to me said
who sings this song
without hesitating i said paul mccartney
and wings then benny and the jets came
on and she asked the same question elton
john i said
i wasn't showing off the responses came
as naturally as breathing
wow she said you listen to a lot of
radio i don't know if she was impressed
when she said that
or if she met something more like wow
you loser you must stay home and listen
to the radio
a lot but i took it as a compliment let
me ask you a question seriously
when you brought this manuscript to the
editor did they
say to you listen gary this is really
nonsense
i mean in seventh grade you i mean they
did not
they did not really it was this was
exactly what they wanted
so you know that gary gets into the
highlight of his life his highlight of
his working career i
assumed it was working on this show but
it turns out
it's not no being a clerk at record
world was the best job gary ever had
according to the book the store was long
and narrow with cash registers on either
side of the aisle
the walls were lined with album covers
70 to 80 on each side
up front on the right where the 45 in
the back left was classical
which no one ever bought and in the way
backward cassettes
down in the basement was the stock room
where we had lunch every day
we went to woolworths and bought chicken
salad sandwiches the description of
record world
the aisles the fluorescent lighting
what about it the fluorescent lighting
can you tell me more because i don't
know much about the fluorescent lighting
went from the front of the store to the
back of the store
and at least every other bulb was on the
verge of burning out it would flicker
and mostly the we never replaced the
bulbs
back in the classical section because
nobody bought anything in the classical
section so there you go
i wasn't there when barbra streisand
released guilty in 1980
but i'm told the response was insane
that had gone down as a single most
harry day
in the history of record world until
december 12
1983 the day thriller was released oh my
goodness
great days in record world i got to tell
you
the day thriller was released at the
record store
was like me doing two tours in vietnam
it was unbelievable i gotta admit howard
some of this is a little difficult to
defend
i know i mean i think on my dying day
what's going to be going through my mind
is gary explaining his years of record
world and his top list
i love being that guy when it comes to
music knowledge how you doing this is
gary i
listen to the radio a lot i also study
liner notes and listen to the jukebox
amassing a record collection that became
my um if i had 245's they were placed
chronologically i love 80s music i got
game girl i was the guy who imported 99
look balloons to record